Eleanor a former colleague reporter
leaves all Craig I was ok so what did
this also teach you about formulating a
story and let me tell you I'll get to
that though I have been a lifelong
reader of Shakespeare who is our
greatest storyteller and our and I
believe our greatest artist and I
learned more about structure and
storytelling from my lifelong reading of
Shakespeare than anywhere else just
doesn't mean that I'm comparing myself
it's just what I learned when I was
reviewing movies for the hollywood
reporter that the arrangement i made
with them is that I would take that job
but that I would review every movie
there would be no second critic I would
review everything and I did it for a
year and a half a year and a half and it
was an extraordinary experience because
that was in the middle 70s but I it gave
me a view of what was going on in the
world of filmmaking and a lot of
filmmakers of my generation were just
beginning to make movies at that time so
I was able to encourage and review those
filmmakers and all the black
exploitation movies were being made I
mean I got a perfume note from Pam Grier
whose performance had praised in the
number of those movies I learned more
about the community Hollywood than I did
about storytelling in that job
and also when you're riding for a trade
paper that's a trade newspaper it's what
what I did is that I I modeled what the
Calle critics had done which is that
they only wrote about what they liked
they didn't go after what they didn't
like so I would look in every movie i
reviewed I would look for what I liked
and it might be wonderfully staged snot
work or wonderful acting in some minor
roles and I didn't dwell on what wasn't
successful about the movie and and I
still do that I you know I need my dose
of movie and I watch movie every day
thank God for turner classic movies and
all those cable channels so I can get my
dose of movie every day and I still look
for what I like you say being in that
job taught you about the film community
what did it teach you what were some of
the unwritten rules that you learned
that could actually still apply today
Hollywood is the gold rush it still is
it's a place where anyone can come forth
with something that the town wants or
some part of the town wants and you can
fall into the world of making movies
it's completely fluid the culture it's
you know it's it's always welcoming and
it can be welcoming there are many many
doorways it whether you know if you want
to make some sort of an exploitation now
they're making exploitation films in
which people cut each other up you know
a lot of those movies are getting made
if you want to make those movies go to
those doorways if you want to get
seriously involved in storytelling go to
cable television that's what they're
doing it and I think that that the town
will always have many many doorways
because the demand for product for is it
software this is the software it is only
growing
you